let's say we have the indefinite
integral
of 1
over
plus
36 plus
x squared
dx
now as you can imagine this is not an
easy integral to solve without
trigonometry there's i can't do u
substitution i don't have the derivative
of this thing sitting someplace this
would be easy if i had a 2x sitting up
there then i would say oh the derivative
of this is 2x i could do u substitution
and and i'd be set but there is no 2x
there so how do i do it well i resort to
our trigonometric identities and let's
see what trig identity we can get here
so the first thing i always do and this
is just the way my brain works i always
like it you know i can see this is a
constant plus something squared which
tells me i should use a trigonometric
identity but i always like it in terms
of 1 plus something squared so i'm just
going to rewrite my integral
as being equal to let me write the dx in
the numerator right this is just times
dx
we run a nicer integral than that so
this is equal to the integral of dx
over
times one plus
x squared
over 36
1 plus x squared over 36 that's another
way to write my integral now let's let's
see if any of our trig identities can
somehow
be substituted in here
for that that would somehow simplify the
problem
so the one that springs to mind and if
you don't know this already i'll write
it down right here is 1 plus tangent
squared of theta
1 plus tangent squared of theta and
let's prove this one tangent squared of
theta this is equal to 1 plus just the
definition of tangent
sine
squared of theta
over cosine squared of theta now one is
just cosine squared over cosine squared
so i can rewrite this as equal to
cosine squared of theta
over
cosine squared of theta that's one
plus
sine squared theta over cosine squared
of theta now that we have a common
denominator now what's cosine squared
plus sine squared definition of the unit
circle that equals one over cosine
squared of theta or we could say that
that equals one over cosine squared one
over cosine is secant so this is equal
to the secant squared
of theta
so if we make the substitution
if we say let's make this thing right
here let's make that thing equal to
tangent of theta or tangent squared of
theta then this expression will be one
plus tangent squared of theta which is
equal to secant squared and maybe
that'll help simplify this equation a
bit
so we're going to say
that x squared
over 36
is equal to tangent
squared of theta let's take the square
root of both sides of this equation and
you get
x
over 6
is equal to the tangent of theta
or that
x is equal to
6 tangent
of theta if we take the derivative of
both sides of this with respect to theta
we get
d x
d theta is equal to what's the
derivative of the tangent of theta
i can show it to you just by going from
these basic principles
right here actually let me let me do it
for you just just in case so the
derivative of tangent theta never hurts
to do it on the side let me do it right
here
so it's going to be 6 times
the derivative with respect to theta of
tangent of theta which we need to figure
out so let's figure it out the
derivative of theta well tangent of
theta well that's the same thing as d d
theta of sine of theta
over cosine of theta that's just the
derivative of tangent
or this is just the same thing as the
derivative
with respect to theta let me scroll to
the right a little bit
of because i never remember the quotient
rule i've told you in the past that it's
somewhat lame of sine of theta
times cosine of theta
to the minus 1 power and what is this
equal to we could say it's equal to
well the derivative of the first
expression or the first function we
could say which is just cosine of theta
so this is equal to cosine of theta
that's just the derivative of sine of
theta times our second expression
times
cosine
of theta to the minus 1. i made i put
these parentheses and put the minus 1
out there because i didn't want to put
the minus 1 here and make you think that
i'm talking about an inverse cosine or
an arc cosine so that's the derivative
of sine times cosine
and now i want to take
plus
the derivative of cosine
so what's the derivative of well not
just cosine the derivative cosine to the
minus 1. so that is
minus 1 times cosine
to the minus 2 power of theta that's the
derivative of this of of the outside
times the derivative of the inside so
let me scroll over more
so that's the derivative of the outside
if the cosine theta was just an x you
would say x to the minus 1's derivative
is minus 1 x to the minus 2
now times the derivative of the inside
of cosine of theta with respect to theta
so that's times
minus sine of theta
and i'm going to multiply all of that
times sine of theta
times sine of theta the derivative of
this thing which is the stuff in green
times the first expression
so what does this equal
these cosine of theta divided by cosine
theta that is equal to 1
and then i have a minus 1 and then i
have a minus sine of theta so that's
plus
plus and what do i have i have sine
squared sine of theta times sine of
theta over cosine squared so plus
sine
squared of theta over cosine squared of
theta which is equal to one plus
tangent squared of theta well what's one
plus tangent squared of theta i just
showed you that that's equal to secant
squared of theta
so the derivative of tangent of theta is
equal to secant squared of theta
all that work to get us fairly something
well it's nice when it comes out simple
so dx d theta this is just equal to
secant
squared of theta so if we want to figure
out what dx is equal to dx is equal to
just both sides times d theta so it's 6
times
secant
squared theta
d
theta
so that's our dx and of course in the
future we're going to have to we're
going to back substitute so we want to
solve for theta so that's fairly
straightforward you just take the arc
tangent of both sides of this equation
you get that the arc
tangent
of x over 6
is equal to theta and we'll save this
for later so what does our integral
reduce to our integral now becomes the
integral of dx what's dx it is
secant
squared theta
d theta
all of that over
this this denominator which is 36 times
1 plus tangent squared of 1 plus
tangent
squared of theta
now we know that this right there is
secant squared of theta i've shown you
that multiple times so this is secant
squared of theta in the denominator we
have a secant squared of theta in the
numerator they cancel out
so those cancel out and so our integral
reduces to lucky for us
6 over 36 which is just 1 over 6
d theta which is equal to 1 over 6 theta
plus c
and now we back substitute using this
result theta is equal to arc tangent of
x over six
so the antiderivative of one over 36
plus x squared is equal to one sixth
times theta theta is just equal to the
arc tangent
the arc tangent of x over 6
plus
c and we're done so that one wasn't too
bad